i wonder as a as a former foreign
secretary yourself you will have no
doubt if you didn't watch it you'll have
picked up in the detail of nazigari
radcliffe's press conference yesterday i
wonder if you think that she perhaps has
a point when she says look if that 400
million payment had anything to do with
my release perhaps that payment could
have been made sooner
i'm not in any doubt that she has more
on the point uh
there was a direct connection
between the 400 million pound debts that
we unquestionably owed
the iranians and nazarene's
detention
i don't either hate the idea of
hostage-taking but it's a reality so far
as the
islamic republic of iran is concerned
and indeed it's if you like an awful
tradition
which goes back
before um the formation of the islamic
republic in 1979 so it's what they do
and the iranians didn't obscure this the
connection it was perfectly played to
anybody who talked to them that the two
were completely connected um the the
british government kept
uh
suggesting that the two were completely
separate which everybody knew was
nonsense
but the money should have been paid
part of the difficult there there was a
lot of nonsense here inside the cameron
government and then when theresa may
took over and actually a bit when boris
johnson did where they were getting
there twisted and saying that well this
was
really a ransom it wasn't remotely a
ransom it's money we owed them
there was no ransom at all let's just
stop mr if it was money that we owed
them presumably it could have been paid
under the labor government that preceded
the conservative one
it could have been indeed uh and i wish
it had been uh and i wish that i'd been
made more fully aware of
this debt
when i was a british foreign secretary i
mean the remarkable thing
is that despite the fact i had
very close uh
connections with the iranians in terms
of diplomatic work and a good
relationship with my opposite number
camel carrizzi
i don't ever recall them raising this
with me and i think at that time it was
under negotiation between their ministry
of defense and our ministry of defense
now i i
wish i had got hold of it because i
think i i mean i would have simply said
well we should pay it and in those days
there were no sanctions to get in the
way
let's talk mr off we can about the
situation in ukraine one i'm sure that
you will be following very very closely
indeed four weeks into this military
conflict what chances are there that
there will not be another four weeks of
conflict that follow
i don't think that i i think the chances
are low that that
this will come to an end in the next few
days i think that
this is as someone else has said now a
war of attrition
in the ukraine and i'm afraid to say
that
many many more people are now going to
end up
killed injured homeless as a result of
putin's
unprovoked aggression
just
extraordinary
in the
third decade or the 21st century
uh that a man should behave in this way
and have the power to do so
but i'm afraid it's going to carry on
and and the crucial thing is
that the world should not get bored
by this so there was always a tendency
to think oh well somebody's just going
to grind on and on and on we you know
let's let's move on and have a look at
something else
but it's crucial that we keep focused
and critical critically it's crucial
that our
european partners france and germany
don't start going soft on
russia
there's a grave danger of that in
germany
where they built up a business model
which is heavily dependent
uh
upon
russian raw materials and russian gas
and oil
a crazy thing to do many of us told them
that
but until they shift away from that
dependence they're going to be pressures
within their system uh to go soft they
shouldn't
so
from your time um it was what was then
the the fco you you i'm sure will be
very well aware of the problems that
there can be in getting prosecutions at
for example the international criminal
court and elsewhere i mean in your mind
is there any prospect of you
absent a revolution in moscow is there
any prospect of vladimir putin facing
justice for what he's done
no i mean not in terms of the
international criminal court i mean i
think it's important these crimes are
investigated um but uh because of the
structure of the treaty behind the
international criminal court
um and i don't believe that uh russia is
a state party to the uh icc it's it's
gonna be virtually impossible uh to uh
getting there without security council
saying so and the security council won't
do so because russia has a veto right
jack straw great to have you in the
program this morning thank you for being
with us
thank you